as a major incident was declared around
the river team in Worcestershire
emergency services confirmed
they'd rescued at least one man from the
river as water filled this valley severe
flood warnings were issued meaning
there's a danger to life the greatest
concern is for the town of temporary
wells
volunteers with lifeboats were helping
the Fire and Rescue Service
to get everyone out safely as houses
along the banks of the team very quickly
became uninhabitable with young children
to keep safe and warm the Kaylie family
escaped with just a few essentials as
river water flowed into their home you
don't know what's going on friends up
baby so we go everything we need over
there
this man had been looking after his
friend's takeaway shop on the main High
Street when the river burst its banks
the water rose so quickly he had to
escape upstairs and wait to be rescued
and we were inside about four o'clock
trying to fight the flood get the water
out I had no luck at all and
unfortunately got to the point we had to
just say just go upstairs cars were
written off people simply didn't have
time to move them as the streets flooded
the fast flowing water made it difficult
and dangerous for people trying to get
out on foot yes the bridge noonim bridge
Eastham is cut off and then going for a
little hair food is just as bad so we
are a bit remote and we are a bit
stranded now storm Dennis brought a
month's worth of rain in just 48 hours
and a record number of flood warnings
were in place right across England
people in Riverside communities were
helpless as their homes and livelihoods
were destroyed people here in temporary
Wells have been fighting for proper
flood defences ever since the last major
flood here back in 2007 but so far very
little has been done meaning now this
town has to fend for itself a small
rural community with businesses that can
ill afford the kind of repair work that
will be needed the government accepts
people across the UK need better
protection from flooding there's
definitely much more to do it is the
reality that with climate change we're
seeing more extreme weather events like
this incidents of this sort are
therefore becoming more frequent anger
frustration and demands for help will
undoubtedly follow but with river levels
still dangerously high keeping people
safe is the main priority